one of the things i want to stress and
this is a kind of a important point
my mind and this is something to think
about as you go forward in your careers
as well is that in many cases computer
science is a team sport and in this case
it definitely is a team activity we like
doing collaborative research at Carnegie
Mellon and therefore for me it's
important to acknowledge the fact that
it's a decent-size team as he said
there's two acts in the first act I'm
going to be mostly talking about
tiramisu system that we have in
pittsburgh public transit and the core
faculty involved in this are myself
anthing tamasic John Zimmerman Charlie
Garrett and Yun Hong some of you may
know John Zimmerman he's relatively
well-known in the h sac communities in
the robotics part where I start talking
about more physical interactions with
things brandon d s and myself are the
ones doing that work i do want to stress
that in all of these projects we have
very strong ties to our stakeholders
it's really important especially when
doing research related to people with
disabilities to always be in contact
with your end users and this allows us
to have a lot of direct input from
people with disabilities especially
people who are blind also we work very
closely with Port Authority of Allegheny
County here in the Bay Area you've got a
gazillion different transit agencies in
the Pittsburgh region we basically only
have one they're woefully underfunded
but very eager to work with us and so
it's been really helpful to have their
insights and knowledge transit is a way
more complex experience than you think
about and of course we've had a number
of class project and stuff now just to
give you a sense as to the size and
scale of this effort this is a non
ordered list well roughly chronological
list of all the different students
postdocs and staff worked on this
project on these projects and I've
probably left a few off because it's
just so hard to keep track trying to
think if there's any highlights in here
he's probably I don't know if he's
actually here is rifai are you here
rafay is he
okay yeah see the beard through me so
rifai was one of our early undergrads is
now at vmware feel free to bother him
and pester him after the session if you
want to ask him what it was like working
on his team way back in the day ok so
our core funding for this research comes
from an agency that cares a lot about
people with disabilities and in
particular we are funded to do work on
accessible public transportation this is
actually a topic I could spend an entire
seminar talking about but I'm just going
to summarize it here this provides you
the context as to why we care about this
particular issue and why we're doing the
work that we're doing there's a lot of
very strong statistics that people with
disabilities rely on public transit to a
degree that is rather significant if you
think about it if you in the United
States we're very car oriented culture
if you are unable to drive a car because
of a particular disability or your
income is so low that you can't afford a
modified vehicle public transit becomes
really important to your daily life
employment social inclusion seeing your
friends and family getting to your
doctor all these things become much more
challenging just as an aside modified
vehicles just to understand can cost
well upwards of a Tesla we'll just put
in that context okay so and of course
you can't resell it because it's been
modified for you so I want to
particularly highlight this notion that
you know most of your students you're
thinking about getting jobs you're all
the biggest thing and finding a job is
an appropriate job for what you want to
do just like that with people with
disabilities is sixty percent uh sorry
fifty percent but the next highest is
actually getting to the job and that
kind of gives a sense as to how big a
deal this is so another kind of key part
to this work and this is what really
draws in Anthony and John is the
combination of this being a very large
scale big data problem but also a design
problem
so most of you probably ride a bus or a
train on a pretty regular basis your
students that's pretty normal but what
you may not realize is that there's a
significant amount of complexity behind
the delivery of that service and that
complexity really makes things difficult
and challenging from the context of
doing anything in it as ubiquitous
computing or participatory sensing
approach and so you can try a variety of
different techniques but in the end
there's always this missing link and
that's where a human interaction can
really make a big impact in terms of
what you're trying to do it's not a
strict ly quantifiable experience either
there's an enormous amount of
stakeholder involvement that changes the
way the service is delivered this can be
as simple as you know someone who
happens to live across the street from
the bus stop really hating that the
buses are always there every day and
trying to subvert the delivery of that
service this can also be something like
a politician who really insists on a
particular transit route staying even
though it's completely inefficient and
threatening to cut cervix threatening
cut funding to the transit agency these
sorts of things happen and then finally
there's all sorts of other factors like
historic vehicles how do you make these
things accessible and so forth so this
is a this is a example as to why an
interdisciplinary approach is necessary
for these sorts of things so we take
approach that combines design
large-scale data a lot of deep knowledge
about the context of the domain we've
even had projects really involving
computer vision on mobile phones and
some of our partner some of our work
that's done by our partners up in SUNY
Buffalo is in the physical space trying
to understand getting down to the level
of if I change the layout of this bus
how does that affect the ability for
people to get on and off the bus quickly
so they have a full full-blown bus with
a vikon system and everything now there
are two approaches to dealing with
accessibility one of the techniques
that's used is the more traditional
assistive technology a wheelchair is a
good example of this these are typically
products or systems that are designed
for a specific capability or specific
disability
they're very effective at delivering
service but you have a niche product
problem in that in many cases there's
only one or two companies providing this
particular technology because there's
such a small market there's not enough
people to buy it so you can't support a
large industry so this has led to a
number of problems over the years in the
accessibility community where a lot of
technologies become orphans because the
person who's behind that company is
usually a one or two person company
something happens in their lives and
they're no longer doing the business and
so that product just disappears off the
market and any research or any sort of
development that went into it is gone
and so the funding agencies have become
increasingly concerned about this
particular problem and so they advocate
a technique called universal design
wherever possible you still need
assistive technology that's critical but
in some cases you can get by with a
what's called universal design and
transit is a really good example of this
so back in the day buses used to be high
floor buses used to have to climb the
steps to get up in the bus school buses
are like this so city buses are like
that in many countries they still are
but in the United States you're seeing
more and more of them down at the
low-floor bus style and that's
intentional for a number of different
reasons the first and foremost is that
people get on and off the bus faster
because you're not climbing steps it's a
lot safer because people aren't tripping
and falling out of the stairs down the
stairs but if you use a wheelchair all
of a sudden that means that the grade
change is significantly smaller so with
multiple steps you had to essentially
have a miniature elevator that would
come out this is called a lift that
would come out from the stairs and raise
a person up and bring them in these
things are these really complex
mechanical structures they break all the
time because it's a niche product niche
manufacturer and niche maintenance so
the approach of low floor vehicles makes
the mechanism much smaller much simpler
because you're only trying to do a great
change of a small amount and so you can
get by with a flip out flip out ramp or
a telescoping wrap and those sorts of
systems survive abuse much better
because they're simpler and so forth but
what's also happening is you're seeing
the same basic ideas in terms of
providing space for a wheelchair and a
bus to also be used for providing space
for other users as well so wheelchairs
in many vehicles the wheelchair space is
also the same space that might get used
by a stroller luggage a bicycle so forth
other vehicles they make it in separate
spaces but the idea is that universal
value to a lot of different users the
other thing to keep in mind about
universal design approaches is that even
if the vast majority of your user base
does not have a disability there's still
cases where they do have a functional
disability for that particular scenario
so you know if it's a rainy dreary night
and you've got your hood up now the
sudden you have restricted peripheral
vision in the dark you have restricted
color perception so all these different
things start adding up and you
essentially have a disability there's
probably at least one bar here in town
that keeps captioning on the TV all the
time because you can't hear the TV so
that's an example of a scenario-based
disability and a number of you probably
ride your bikes with headphones on you
can't hear a thing around you you're
effectively deaf while you're riding
your bike so universal design helps
solve these problems another core
techniques that we use is that was
interesting I'm all right we are general
plying technology and crowd sourcing in
both areas to try and make a difference
and they do stitch together because both
techniques actually have some crowd
sourcing elements to them both from the
smartphone approach which is the tomb
soup project but also in our transit
station helper robots project just as a
kind of a prelude to this before I get
deep into the into the tiramisu case
people ask why would you need a robot to
help in a transit station there are lots
of transit stations that are really hard
to navigate really confusing even if
you're cited a brand new transit station
for example has this crude user design
hack of a you know rather easy to read
wayfinding technique for sighted users
you can imagine how difficult it is to
get around a complex confusing transit
station if you're blind furthermore if
you can't see the way crowds are moving
through the spaces and you don't under
stand where the bottlenecks are in terms
of crowds so I'll come back to this in a
bit but I want us more focus on
smartphones right now so like any good
HCI approach we started from the
beginning with you know human centered
techniques interviews focus groups
various other design explorations rifai
was active in some of these particular
projects and one of the early papers is
this one here back in 2010 and this
included efforts related to service
design I'm sorry service blueprinting
trying to understand where the various
breakdowns and service delivery were
where the different problems occurred
keep in mind that under the a DA and
other regulations transit isn't is
supposed to be by default accessible and
it generally is but where you run into
problems with accessibility in public
transit it tends to be because of a
service breakdown a driver saying that
their lift is broken when it's not a
newspaper company putting their
newspaper box in the wrong spot at a bus
stop then now blocks access to the
vehicle it can be something as simple as
failing to clear snow out of a bus stop
and the resulting in an icy sheet around
the the bus the bus stop area and so
these sorts of breakdowns are actually
the source of the vast majority of
accessibility problems so we went
through this process and came back with
a core approach that we wanted to pursue
which is a CO design approach and the
idea is that the people who are using
the public transit also could provide
value to improve that service delivery
this already happens in a number of
systems that you already use the ratings
on amazon the ratings on yelp these are
examples of co-production of value in a
system where your end users are making
that system more valuable and there's
shared value to everybody through the
process and the question was could we do
this in public transit and this was
motivated by two particular data needs
that our end-users highlighted to us the
first is that if you're have a
disability you want to know when the bus
is going to show up I mean we all want
to know but if you have a disability
it's really important for a number of
different reasons first whether it's
true or not there's definitely perceived
perception that you are going to get
mugged what you're more likely to get
mugged if you have a disability they do
tend to get mugged more often you also
have this issue of exposure to inclement
weather if you have particular
disabilities exposure to cold rain that
sort of thing can be much more severe in
terms of your health than people without
disabilities and finally it does take
for some people the mobility is somewhat
slow so it does take some time to get to
a stop so knowing good good information
helps in that regard the fullness one
was an interesting one we didn't even
think about this in you know I've been
in this space for a while now and it
didn't even occur to me until one of our
participants kind of uttered that one
line that changes the course of your
research and this happens to the
researchers and all sorts of fields
where he said this particular thing
you're working on is really cool I like
it but if the bus is full i can't get on
so yeah because his wheelchair takes up
a lot of space actually technically in
some in some locations the bus driver is
supposed to kick people off to make room
for a wheelchair user you can imagine
how many bus drivers actually do this so
so this this particular piece of data
was really important to us and we
realized there were other people with
this other types of disabilities where
knowing if you're going to be able to
get a seat or not is really really
useful so from this we said we'll go
after these two points but then we kind
of got ins this issue of well if you're
doing crowdsourcing or co.design type
approach you're not going to get perfect
results so we do want to get sense as to
what's good enough to provide value to
everybody and then we have this kind of
long range let's hope it works kind of
idea out there if you live in London or
certain boroughs in New York City you
have a very strong positive brand
identity to your transit agency you know
the underground you know the particular
train in Brooklyn or something like that
it means something to you it has value
it's it's a source of pride most transit
agencies this is not truth right there a
means to an ends rather than the ends
and so therefore it's just something you
have to put up
with to get through your life one of the
questions is is that by generating this
co.design experience could you hopefully
maybe create a better sense of ownership
for the public for that particular
transit system so that you feel more
connected to your transit agency and
this has strong implications in terms of
digital government and other things like
that because most transit agencies are
heavily subsidized by your taxes the
fares are actually relatively small well
if they're not cheap but the affairs
actually do have less impact on their on
them on the budgets as as maybe the
taxes do which is why they're so
susceptible to funding problems at the
government so to summarize kind of where
we are now and then I'll kind of back
into some of the stories behind this I
wanted to give you a sense of the system
we've been deployed now since 2011 when
you want to provide information about a
vehicle particular bus you click on that
you tell it where you're you tell
everybody where you're going and then
the system asks you to say how full the
bus is and then start recording and then
you record your trip that information is
fed back into the system as real-time
data using machine learning techniques
and then that's shared with all the
other riders if we don't have someone on
a particular bus but we have a lot of
data for that particular bus we're
pretty sure we can give you an estimate
will generate out a historic data as
well and historic data sometimes has
fullness sometimes it doesn't it kind of
depends on the confidence we have in a
distribution this approach has worked
very well we've been as I said we've
been deployed for a while we have both
Android and iPhone and we are
technically deployed in New York City
and Syracuse but we haven't advertised
and haven't recruited participants there
so it works there but you won't see any
interesting data but mostly in
Pittsburgh we've generated 183 200 180
3250 trip contribution data points from
people this is not counting how often
people have opened the app and used it
without contributing and the
is just the actual trips not how long
that you know so you only get counted
once basically on your trip as an aside
by going out and deploying this and
doing research in the wild we've kind of
raised our profile among the community
and then the process picked up a couple
innovation awards that typically are not
the sorts of things that you get when
you're a researcher so this is a kind of
a nice thing to do and it's worth
considering as a nice byproduct of doing
research in the wild and sponsors love
it so we started with a closed field
test we wanted to test out the system
make sure it worked kind of check out
all the bugs sort out all the problems
in the if you do research with people
with disabilities these sorts of pilot
tests you starts a small scale kind of
visit working test you typically do not
recruit people with disabilities they
are a limited resource and you don't
want to run out of people with
disabilities so quite often you'll
recruit regular people to test sorry
people without disabilities to test out
ideas so this was actually people
without disabilities but we recruited
them from a specific part of town the
oakland area if you're familiar with
pittsburgh and set them loose we paid
them for their time so because we paid
them they probably traced more than they
would normally would and we ended up
with about just over half of the rides
being traced even with this small number
of people and the number of all possible
trips that they could experience and see
they actually saw about 13% value-added
I should explain whether impression is
each one of these rows is an impression
in our terminology so if you are so this
is one impression too and so forth so of
the impressions that they saw because we
log it so we know what they saw six
percent were real time seven percent
historic and this is with just only 28
people as they're running around using
the app so this was really cool but he
also very cool was that people were
using the report function we have a
little report function on the app allows
people to document things they
experience that are kind of more single
instance things like a broken seat that
someone encountered and took a picture
and when we've done it in our early work
we asked people how often do you call up
the transit agency how often do you file
a form on their web page and the answer
for most people without disabilities is
0 how many of you have ever contacted
transit agency with a comment or
complaint a twitter twitter does not
count that's that this actually was
before transit agency start getting
active in Twitter yeah so very low but
now all of a sudden we have all these
reports coming in from people because
it's there in their hands and easy to do
and of course the traditional metrics
came back very high as well yeah we know
when they open the app definitely right
right half of it for the times that they
open the app we we of those yeah about
half yeah we we treat this OE treats we
we also take a sessions based approach
based on a 15 minute window so if you
open the app and then go to like your
calendar and come back or something
that's just once sure yeah okay so
getting on as an aside you know this
report function this is actually
something we thought we wanted to do
very early on something that was
important for people with disabilities
again the breakdowns these service
breakdowns these these you know random
problems out in the middle of nowhere at
a bus stop that the ad a coordinator for
a transit agency might never go to how
do you document these experiences and we
looked at the traditional forms a call
center and web forms these are the
typical techniques and so these these
animal context fall into an audio call
or something like a Twitter or text text
message type of documentation of
something and we cross that against no
media photos and videos so it was a 2 by
3 and what came out of this work is that
almost everybody prefers the text and
photo combination furthermore all of the
quality metrics on we had Raiders check
the results of terms of what people
documented come back as texts photos is
the right approach as well
to be clear Port Authority was going to
let us take a bus shelter from their
graveyard but we're going to need a
crane truck and we're going to chop it
up and then resaw tree rivet it back
together and and it was looking like it
was going to be really hard to do that
and so we built the fake bus shelter in
our lab complete with a 12 x 12 banner
of a backdrop seen tempered glass the
whole deal and brought in industrial
designer did a really good job on
various different things and it came
back but it came back with Texan photo
and and the theory that we have as to
why stems from a particular metric on
one of the survey data points which was
social comfort people were had much much
higher social comfort when doing text
versus audio so you're standing at the
bus stop and you're documenting a
problem and so you it's it's more
comfortable from a social context to use
text idea why what's wrong with audio
it's private so text is private right
everyone knows you are complaining you
pull up that phone and you start telling
someone about a problem everyone around
you immediately knows you're complaining
so we think that that's a strong effect
in this particular context having said
this people with specific disabilities
have trouble typing large amounts of
text and the phones so we still do
provide a call button that goes straight
to the agency yeah I this sea or the
Navy playing a role there's multiple
measure invasion yeah but it seems like
it's about also groups like the social
cover it seems like admitting about
who's the audience am i complaining to
the authority or in this telling cutters
right so in this particular study was
you're you're you're telling the agency
about a problem that you're experiencing
it well soon and this held true for both
people with disabilities
disabilities see so put in the app
you're not you're telling other people
other than that right you're actually
you're actually one slide ahead I'll get
a second before I forget though one of
the things that we would like to do is
be able to support the photo photo
capability for people who are blind and
so one of the students came up with a
technique that allows a blind allows the
system to improve the image composition
of a picture so if you're blind you can
roughly aim the camera but your image
composition is probably going to be
somewhat difficult to get right and so
the so computer vision runs locally on
the phone in real time to help you take
a better picture using sound feedback
that particular code is not in our sin
our app it burns CPU like nobody's
business because it fires up the GPU but
that particular code is actually
available on github and it's marinelle
will be presenting this particular to KY
paper at KY next week so if you're
curious about that you can find her in
the audience and get pointers to that
and yeah during the study someone at you
we got interesting things like someone
asked to take a picture of their dog
that had come with them so people who
are blind do like taking pictures so
anyway going to your question of the
report so when we release the system out
to the wild we intentionally triaged
every single report that came in for a
big chunk of time we did this we took
the first thousand reports that came in
and pair of undergrads is that through
and coated them all and for you guys
it's coating yeah yeah yeah yeah we were
talking over lunch about coding eye
tracking by hand frame by frame so
they're the kind of the short story as
to what came out of this is that people
are more than willing to document point
of pain experiences and mobile apps the
twitter is a good example of a technique
that's actually used nowadays pretty
well by a lot of transit agencies and
furthermore people who don't have
disabilities actually documented cases
of just what they perceived as discrim
nation and sent that in and that was
something we suspected might happen but
we weren't really sure it would happen
so we're rather pleased to see it
occurring but by and large an underlying
effect that came out of this is a real
strong desire for a dialogue to occur
between the riders and their agency or
at least riders and riders as well and
so actually one of the weird oohing
going through a major update of our
stalker right now and in large part to
support that particular capability as
the years went on we had continued
discussions with the transit agency we
had been triaging out the ones that were
specific to the transit agency and
forwarding them along to the agency but
it turns out that yeah they're useful
they're interesting they're valuable to
them but they can't actually take action
on any data that came in so even though
discrimination was being seen by people
they couldn't do anything about it
because of the way that the union
contract rules were set up that
prohibited them from using our data for
disciplinary action because of the way
that we had been set up in our structure
we weren't really trying to do this this
was a byproduct of what we were doing we
thought maybe they might use it for it
but they can't yeah well the the union
rules are very specific to disciplinary
action yeah for fixing things there is
evidence that these sorts of systems do
have appeal to these agencies
SeeClickFix asst you know still going on
things like that but that wasn't you
know we were interested in whether or
not they would use this but it's prob
our results were probably heavily biased
by our particular agency during this
process Port Authority was going through
massive budget cuts so they barely had
enough people to even answer the phone
much less read our stuff and send it
forward to the necessary person so
unfortunately in our context probably
the wrong place the wrong time it's
interesting walking into port
authority's offices I used to go in for
a different project years ago when
funding was fine it's it's like a ghost
town now compared to what it used to be
so this is probably an artifact of them
just not having the labor to chase these
things down which is another reason why
we're going to a more dialogue based
model so that riders can
each other with information about things
so the nice thing about having a system
that's used by a large number of people
for a number of years is that in the
general public is that we can do some
really interesting research we have a
bunch of different questions that we're
exploring at large scale this paper here
I've cited because I'm going to skip
over and not going to talk about it but
the transportation people really
interested in how well does a
crowdsource system do because these the
official de formal systems where you buy
the gear and mounted on a vehicle for a
city the size of Pittsburgh it's going
to be you know millions and millions and
millions of dollars so a quote-unquote
free or almost free service is very
attractive to them and we have some data
on how well that works out now since we
started this project it became
politically possible for port authority
to actually buy an AVL system so now
we're starting to look at the question
of how do you merge this data together
because we have advantages that the
cysts the onboard systems don't have in
terms of data collection but they have
the coverage so we're looking at how do
you fuse the two together I do want to
focus on a on a paper that is probably a
lot more interesting to members of this
particular community we looked at the
contribution effect so the app that we
have has a nuance in that we're asking
you to contribute data after you've
already gotten value out of the system
once you're on the bus you don't really
need to have our app open anymore right
it's kind of you know you got some data
from us please help out and chip in and
help everyone else out kind of deal as
opposed to we're not going to give you
data until you start helping us and so
there's there's literature and research
out there that suggests that quid pro
quo models work very well for certain
crowd source and experiences you see
this in job sites dating sites that sort
of thing you can't see the job until you
put your resume up those sorts of those
sorts of sorts of quid pro quo kinds of
experiences and so the question was with
this sort of negative kind of pressure
where something bad happens if you don't
contribute
this actually work in this kind of space
and so over 10 months we did something
that no app company here in the Bay Area
would even consider doing we willfully
flirted with upright I'm sorry a revolt
among our users and assigned our users
into one of three categories one
category was none the same as usual just
work the way it worked no changes the
third was request if you used a bunch of
data and you cross the threshold in
terms of how much you use versus how
much you contributed we have two
different thresholds they actually
turned out to not be effect you've got
to pop up basically saying you know hey
want to contribute it'd be nice help out
kind of a request type of a thing in the
third condition if you cross this
threshold you're told you're not getting
any data not even the schedule printed
schedule data until you start
contributing and we use a big bold red
blocked on every single impression and
we did this for 10 months which is a
really long time to do a study like this
but we wanted to see the decay we wanted
to see dropout rates and you can't do
that over the span of you know one month
or two months and so by doing it over 10
months you can really see the effect of
this in the end we brought it back to
the control at the very end to see what
finally happened and the short story is
it works it does lead to people
generating more data per individual the
downside is that people abandon your app
significantly faster request had no
impact it was identical to control you
all really good at pushing through
buttons that have no teeth okay the but
the quid pro quo really did lead to a
lot faster abandoned meant of the
software and some very colorful one star
reviews in the App Store which is why
our ratings are so bad
but that's the nice thing about being a
research group is that we can do these
sorts of studies and and we don't have
investors yelling at us factory j'en
seas are happy that we're doing it so so
this is an interesting thing to consider
if you're doing research and a personal
pet peeve of mine every time I get a
funding review request that comes back
saying why do we need to do this read
why does the federal government need to
fund this research aren't the app
companies doing this themselves answer
is no there's no way they would do this
but this is the sorts of research that
is fun as an aside if you ever run a
study like this with thousands and
thousands and thousands and thousands of
data points you know most human studies
if you get a significant correlation
that means that you throw it in the
paper because it's interesting at this
size n we got a significant correlation
on one of our things for a coefficient
of point zero point zero point zero one
and a reviewer rightfully pointed this
out to us so as a team we had to start
thinking about what's a functional
difference in terms of some of our
results not just a statistical
difference I see a hand back there well
that was the quid pro quo case oh right
they would only get data if they
contributed in either why don't you why
do you even you given the option p not
regard so you're saying why don't we
trace automatically in the background
yeah okay so what happens is in this
works great for ways I told you this we
r greater way works great for Google
Maps it does not work in transit many of
you are probably familiar with the
stacked bus phenomenon where are two
buses of the same route end up right
next to each other now you have a
problem is to which bus are you actually
measuring the really nasty case is when
you have buses that go over the same
routes where you might not be able to
disambiguate the two different routes
until a quarter mile is gone by
sometimes even longer there's routes in
Pittsburgh where they start downtown
they go all the way out to Oakland which
is really less like 10 minutes worth a
ride and then they split and even there
they only split from six but six
different routes down to three different
you know so there's a sort of the
outbound trip problem where a bus they
all start kind of leaving the same way
but then they all start splintering out
you just don't know which which bus the
person's on the other kind of really
kind of nasty case which is a little
more insidious is that if the schedule
says a bus is coming now and in 10
minutes but a bus arrives in six minutes
which one is it and so there's these
sorts of situations where you just have
to rely on the human and the humans
perception in their judgement to give
you the data and so that's why we can't
do it automatically we are thinking
about how to do it we've got ideas on
how to streamline the experience but a
fully automated process is probably
going to be really difficult to do and
have really good coverage because of the
complexity of the system so as I said
we're now merging the AVL this gives us
a large amount of coverage but this
coverage has weaknesses for example you
don't get anything about fullness and
the location on these buses is generally
driven off of a GPS system while your
phone has GPS and Wi-Fi so your phone
has better better localization
capability and so we're playing around
with different methods for hybrid fusion
of data we're also going through a major
redesign i mentioned that dialogue is an
important feature and we're seeing that
the report function as nice as it is
doesn't really lead to a lot of change
so we want to go to a systems that allow
people to have dialogue with each other
so people can help each other on a
qualitative things like the air
conditioner is broken on this bus and so
maybe you might want to catch a
different bus or things like there's
broken glass all over this bus stop or
something like that and we're thinking
about how do you support dialogue
between riders and riders but also
riders an agency and this version
hopefully will come out very soon we
also are adding in user accounts we've
had complaints from a number of our
users where they've gotten experience
running on their particular phone and
then they switch phones and then they
have to reload everything on there
because it because the nature of the way
we've set up our IR being the way that
our app works you're strictly anonymous
on your phone and so in fact if you
switch to a new phone you have to set up
everything all over again so we're
moving to user accounts as a byproduct
that also allows us to start asking
questions like demographics
you have a disability what kind of
disability do you have those sorts of
questions but we're still allowing
people to use the app without a user
account we just restrict what they can
do so I'm going to switch gears to the
robot robots project and there is a
crowdsourcing element to this too but
I'll get to that in a minute I am going
to talk very specifically about blind
users but many of us many of the
features and functions I'm talking about
having Universal Design characteristic
and that they support people who maybe
don't know the language in the
particular city there in maybe they have
a cognitive disability maybe they're
completely fried from flying at the sole
on a 14-hour flight and they don't have
a clue where they are much less what
time of day it is these sorts of things
come in valuable for a large number of
users but for this particular study I'm
gonna talk about blind users so guide
dogs are a great solution for a large
number of mobility challenges if you're
blind the problem is that blind is that
guide dogs are particularly expensive
and much more rare than you'd think it
takes a lot to get it the dog has to be
a very certain temperament and go
through a lot of particular training to
be an effective a guide dog for people
who are blind there are a number of
smartphone apps that do support
independent navigation around the
community they're very effective
outdoors where GPS is plentiful the
moment you get indoors things start
breaking down and there are some
approaches and techniques that if people
have come up with for indoor navigation
my colleague bernadine d/s for example
uses a Wi-Fi triangulation technique
that's been quite effective but you'd
like to have the situation where the
smartphone a robot that behaves like a
guide dog or even a robot at an
information desk all are part of the
same system architecture sharing the
same information with each other so that
information that is relevant in one
particular part of the transit
experience is shared across the mall a
good example of this is you're coming
into a new station you don't know it
very well
your phone let's this you know your
sister the system knows where you are
because your phone says you're coming in
to that station the robot meets you at
the door of the Train ask your escorts
you through the station maybe you might
need to stop to get some help from the
from the robot in terms of manipulation
capability and then you're going to go
out side and move on to wherever your
destination is but there's construction
on the sidewalk outside well you'd like
all of these things to know about that
construction so that the routing can be
altered and impacted accordingly
likewise the particular station might be
really hard to walk through certain
areas at certain times a day because of
crowds that move with rush hour or other
artifacts like that so this is you have
a thing about this from a systems level
perspective and how could crowdsourcing
be useful in that particular context so
again traditional HCI techniques you
start early with your concept
development you bring in a handful of
people to test out some ideas and then
you flush those out and build them into
more and more robust systems that you
then do some experiences with how many
of you know the Baxter robot guessing a
handful of you okay so this is a
commercial robot designed for
manufacturing sites we have to teach a
robot to do some small task and then
move it on to another thing and it's
good for kind of manipulation and
inspection type of things it's great for
working with people who are blind
because this robot is designed with
almost no pinch points you can put your
fingers just about anywhere on this
robot and not worry about your fingers
getting pinched which if you're blind
that's kind of a big deal and likewise
it's very compliant robot if this robots
moving its arm past you and your head
happens to be in the way it it hurts but
not like so much that you end up in the
hospital just kind of bounces off you
right it's like a clumsy neighbor and
and so it's a relatively safe robot to
be around which is why we really like
this particular robot for the purposes
of our research now I'll acknowledge
this is not the sort of thing you would
see in a transit station but for
research purposes it's a great test bed
for us and so we're using this for the
manipulation that
vides so we're looking at a bunch of
different interactions that might work
well the one I'm particularly interested
in I come from a cognitive human factors
background so I had to go through all
sorts of training on mental rotation and
try and conversion between verbal and
spatial information when I'm giving you
directions on how to get out of this
building I might say you go through
those doors you turn right you go up the
stairs do a u-turn and walk out the
front door I'm giving you spatial
instructions at the same time I'm giving
you verbal instructions so you're
getting redundant information in two
different modes and it not actually
makes it much easier for you to remember
it now excited people just do this
naturally we just do it if you're blind
not only are you not getting the
redundant information but you're not
getting spatial information you're
getting verbal information so now you
have to convert that verbal information
into spatial not spatial information and
then work from there and the technique
that's used by most mobility experts
with people who are blind is the blind
person puts their hand out and then the
person who's trying to give them an
instruction on where to go puts their
finger on the palm and draws it while
they're giving instructions and so
that's really cool and comfortable if
you're dealing with someone who's really
used to doing this but if you're dealing
with a random station agent or someone
else in the translation who might
interact with a blind person once every
you know three months that can be very
disturbing and uncomfortable grabbing a
robot's hand that's an entirely
different story so we came up with some
we worked on some of these concepts and
came up with some scripted examples of
robot behaviors brought in orientation
mobility and other experts of in terms
of teaching people who are blind how to
be independent in the world refined our
ideas and then brought in people who are
blind and had them grab the robot and
try it out and test out some of these
experiences and now what we're doing is
taking this particular direction giving
a case and moving it up to earn a more
autonomous capability where the robots
doing some path planning and then
converting that path planning into
gestures and
and were curious to see how this works
out now one of the things that came out
of this is that was kind of unexpected
again we should have seen it coming is
how do you describe a robot to a blind
person okay when you see a robot what
you see on that robot tells you a lot
about what its capabilities are what its
affordances are someone was talking
about affordances earlier today what its
cable to do what is safe to do around it
these things these are things you pick
off automatically when you look at a
robot if you're blind none of that is
there so the description of the robot
becomes really important especially if
you're trying to get people to feel
comfortable about reaching out and
grabbing it by the way there's some
really bad ways that you can say it's
okay for people to touch a robot so so
we've been actually looking a little bit
at this problem of how do you how do you
tell a blind person that you know it's
okay to reach out and grab this robot
and it has these capabilities and we've
actually been doing some online surveys
with audio clips and so forth to look at
that most of this has been driven from
data and feedback that we got from the
people who came in in terms of their
recommendations and suggestions but
that's a fun little project to think
about especially if you're dealing with
populations that maybe don't have the
perceptual capabilities that you have
what does it mean when they encounter
your technologies what if what do they
need to know about what that technology
is capable of doing now the
crowdsourcing element as I said you'd
like to be able to take data from once
from from people who are out there in
this transit experience and then feed
that data back into the system the
example that's used earlier or the
construction on the sidewalk so what
we've started to do is look at
techniques for people to generate pred
from experiences around you know so
don't go this way go this way leave
audio notes a particular spots dumping
all that data into a architecture that
allows the same information to be used
by the robotic systems as opposed to
just a peer-to-peer phone based system
but the idea is that this sort of stuff
will be available to everybody who uses
it an important new
is that you want that data to have to
have come from someone that you trust
can generate and provide the data that
is actually useful if you're not
familiar with people with particular
disability what seems like an obvious
thing to you might actually be
completely opposite of what they need or
want and so the idea is that you'd like
to have some control over the sources
and so this architecture includes this
notion of trusted sources and there's a
variety of different layers and levels
to that as well do you just trust people
you know do you trust other people who
have similar needs as you do you trust
people who have certain credentials and
so forth now we're still early in this
project in terms of the robots project
we're not obviously deployed like we are
with tiramisu but we do have money in
our budget for a second Baxter and that
box will be put out in the world and we
will be leaving it there and letting
people interact with it over time and
this is something that a number of us
have gotten much more verbal and vocal
about Carnegie Mellon this actually
stems from a transportation program
called traffic 21 where there was a
strong request by a local foundation to
get technology out into the world and
let it be used by the general public so
they can take advantage of all the
bleeding edge stuff that we're doing at
Carnegie Mellon and we want to do this
as well in the robotics project this is
kind of an important detail to doing
interesting work the downside is that
it's a lot harder you have to work on
longer time scales and you have to be
worried about things like maintenance
robustness the system really can't crash
you know we were fixing a tiramisu
server bug on a Friday evening you've
got to be willing to do this sort of
stuff when you go out into the world
like this but you get really great data
and you can tackle questions that you
just can't do in the lab and so this is
really a fascinating and fun way of
doing research and we're excited to do
this kind of stuff I want to leave time
for questions the standard sponsor slide
with all the different sources for the
variety of work that I've shown you
today and then
some pointers to some of the web pages
tech bridge world is where the robotic
stuff is based and the tiramisu app is
based at that location but I do want to
stress and go back to that earlier
comment as our stakeholders are really
important to us when you do want to do
research that does work with a
particular small user population that
has very specific needs it's really
important to get to know that population
and keep them involved in your research
it's really easy to make naive mistakes
unless you have closed continuous
interaction with those stakeholders and
I'm not just talking about people with
disabilities I'm also talking about the
people at the transit agencies that we
talk to and with that I'll take
questions yeah Baxter doing so well so
within the example with the directions I
we have actor do that put it puts us
hand like this and it then does the path
for you and walks you through it it
spins its risk to do the turns and so
forth interestingly you can't just take
linear you can't just take it and scale
it down because if I tell you to go that
way three feet and then that way 100
feet you could actually make the person
fall over right you know because they're
trying to keep it in so you have to do
some interesting scaling effects to keep
it safe so then to end effectors for
this one we closed the river so it's
like a fat finger almost like this so
there's a there's an orientation to the
picture one more do you think three
things new robot would be better it's
just the wartime more it's a lot smaller
yeah so that that is for that particular
task yeah I mean you can make you can do
use a much smaller technique you could
even make your own custom thing for it
we are using this particular robot for a
couple different reasons the first is
there's other concepts out there there's
other functions out there that are
probably valuable to people with
disabilities and by having a system
that's more capable
higher-end our research won't be bounded
by that by the by the technology we have
an artist book it will still be valid
but won't be as bounded as it would be
as if we had specialized pieces of
hardware the Baxter is actually in in
the mind of a student it doesn't seem
cheap but in the mind of a faculty it is
actually cheered so yeah other questions
everybody's very virulent everybody
thinking about their trip to Korea hope
you like kimchi yeah uh so when you guys
came up the idea for term sue and all of
basically the experiment that you did
with pro quo yeah um how did you compare
that to so obviously you know people are
happy that you're doing that your
research here how did how do you compare
that to industry and how can you
actually apply that research you've done
to episode industry in the tech
constraints or so when when we first
started doing tiramisu and I think we're
Faye you probably remember this too it
was discussion actually of doing
gamification techniques positive
reinforcement for contributing and
that's where a lot of the research area
is in so you know so that there are
certain contexts where quid pro quo make
a complete sense these you know these
dating and job sites and so forth but
most people who work in a space that's
more you know casual transient short
term type of experience tend to focus on
these reward based systems mostly
because of organizations like like
Foursquare kind of showing that it can
be quite effective is motivating people
to do things so positive reinforcement
is a very strong and well-known effect
but at the time that we started the
study nobody's nobody had really tried
negative reinforcement in these kinds of
casual kind of less high-stakes
experiences right dating and job sites
that's a very high stakes there's a
willingness to expend a certain amount
of effort
on to contribute to get what you want
but in this sort of thing it's a little
more lower sticks casual type of
experience and so we felt that it was
important to explore this just to see
because everybody's they're kind of the
feeling was it's probably a bad idea but
maybe it wasn't and and and so it turns
out that it's a mixed result if you
really care about contribution you
really want a lot of contributions then
yeah maybe you do a quid pro quo
approach and you just are willing to
sacrifice your your user base but in
other cases you might not want to do
that in an our case we don't want to do
that it also biases any study we do from
now on so that's why we turned it off
but yeah well so did quid pro quo really
get people to contribute more or dad
just the per capita contribution rate oh
sorry but you sucked out all the people
who weren't going to contribute a lot ah
nobody people left in your sample of
people who contributed a lot whereas
there are lots of people who so the red
line is quicker well I apologize for the
look that has you're amazing so yeah so
this is how many days did they use the
app so right so you see that it doesn't
suck them out as fast as you would think
they just they decay faster but they
don't you don't have that kind of clip
that you would expect to see and that's
kind of an interesting result too yes I
think I was asking now I'm sure there
are a handful of users who open the app
saw block is that oh hell no and walked
away right right but I'm wondering is it
seems like possible any but people were
assigned it at first time they opened it
so it wasn't like they started in
control and moved in it was it was at
first instance so these renew all means
all year so I'm assuming what it's going
to happen is that they're going to be
high performers who are going to record
no matter what you do yeah which is on
most social site right we we have that
curve yeah when you have p.m. who are
basically like lurkers in a positive way
like what
if I value but they just don't they're
not get ready right so if you're if you
take these people on you and you say you
gotta contribute basically the people
who are more likely to draw are going to
be the lurkers right I think you are
probably correct about that but I don't
think we actually explicitly did that
analysis we are doing so we recently
introduced the ability to make a
contribution just by spotting a bus or
buses passing and you say I saw the bus
pass and we're doing an analysis by
comparing that to the to the traditional
tracing technique and seeing the guy in
that one on there are differences in the
groups but we're actually seeing pretty
common behaviors across the board that
paper will get submitted soon but that
one we're seeing kind of it affects
everybody but that's a different kind of
thing that's making maybe that's that's
changing that's changing the the effort
not so much the negative cost sorry yeah
the only what I was making which I
didn't you already get so it's just yeah
if you get the people who are workers
more likely to drop out then your
average of participation is gonna go up
yeah left or night ah so again I don't
remember this capers like 2,000 we did
the analysis in like 2001-11 I don't
remember exactly or 12 does matter I
don't remember exactly but I don't
remember exactly we looked at that
particular data point it would be
interesting to see how other people
contributed sort of minimum at plus
epsilon or did you just sort of like
create a minimum wall that everyone just
try to pile barely over or did you
actually we do have anecdotal evidence
that some people did just do that where
they just stepped over the line and they
figured out they figured out the right
technique for doing that we did do an
analysis of this particular question
you're asking about but I don't remember
if it's in the paper that paper was
really dense we had that actually we
couldn't include everything I saw a
question yeah yeah um I is curious if
you had any comments or thoughts about
tiramisu relative to Brian Harris's work
on one person yeah so one bus away so
Brian did that work with Kari Watkins
Brian was the coder and Carrie was the
transportation person
I talked with Carrie a lot I've actually
tried to get funding with Carrie
together to do some cross analyses
between one bus away and anterior Mesut
haven't been fortunate to do it to get
that money yet but we do want to do some
collaborative work in terms of comparing
things that are happening in one bus
away things that are happening in our
system one bus away is running in New
York City and when we're ready to go
when our system is advertised in New
York City then we'll have a common data
set because one of us away is not
running in Pittsburgh and that would be
a really interesting thing to be able to
do at that point but we haven't gotten
to that to that point yet mainly because
the resources haven't been there to do
it but yeah we do want to do that when
Carrie and I occasionally at various
conferences will sit down in scheme on
non things yeah I'm interested in kind
of in rolla exploration and Dan in your
data can you can you characterize people
as may be explorers or they kind of rice
satisficing thing all right gradually if
like a route change happened um an
exactness shot seemed good for that type
of it so um in the impact of riders with
disabilities we do have some qualitative
data suggesting that the app did I did
support exploration and awareness of new
routes and new trip opportunities on
we're in the process of seeing if we can
tease that out in the quantitative data
but we certainly have qualitative data
Kari Watkins in her work back and her
thesis work did show that when you do
provide people with real-time
information they do tend to walk more on
and people and you think that this is
the case where it's like I'm waiting for
the bus but I could walk that same trip
well it actually is also things like oh
the bus stop a block away has a bus
that's coming sooner I will walk there
so there is evidence that these kinds of
apps do lead people to become more aware
of options that are out there most of
this is survey and qualitative data
we're hoping to figure out if we can
tease it out from the data from this
particular study
entirely sure if that's possible but
we'd like to do that we are looking at
travel behavioral patterns I mean trying
to understand some of the details
related to that but that's more looking
at how people move through a system as
opposed to does the software allow them
to do more things now you'll notice we
don't have a trip planner in our app our
app was explicitly designed for
commuters to the to kind of core things
that came out of our app is we wanted to
support independent travel by people
with disabilities in the city using
universal design techniques the for
example the iphone one is voiceover
compatible but we really wanted to focus
on daily travel and daily travel is
typically very very much you know you
know the route you're going for and so
that's why we didn't spend any effort
and putting in a trip planner again
we're research team we don't have you
know millions of dollars of VC funds
behind us so we just focused on on that
so we don't have that sort of discovery
tool or interaction built into the
software but some of the other apps that
do do that that would be an interesting
question I think Kerry might might
actually have some data on that I don't
know for sure but I suspect you might
I'm going to give him a chance because
you yeah yeah in your control data set
we've been doing the but basically the
contribution yes um roughly could you
give a rough estimate of what your
contribution rates you were getting on a
picture is that um I think I have that
table on here so devices is kind of like
users if you think about the likelihood
of someone deleting the app or getting a
new phone in the middle of the study
relatively small so you could think
about that as from it as a devices is
kind of analogous to users and so you
can see is in the control case we're
seeing about fifteen percent of the time
type of experience but in quid pro quo
it goes up higher so yeah but that
seventeen percent is not significantly
different from the 15 even if this
sample size
like per day that is a percentage of uh
I'm trying over exactly which this table
is this is I think this is an you have
to double check the paper to see if I
get this wrong I believe that is the
light I think that is the you know I
don't want to say cuz I'm i think i'm
just going to refer you to the paper
because i might be getting that wrong i
might be i'm not get this wrong because
in some of our research we're finding
contribution rates near ten percent but
in others we have different numbers
depending on how we're measuring
contribution for a particular study yeah
so i don't want to say that because i
might be giving you the contribution
rate based on a different study so
thankfully the metric using a different
study so i don't want to say because i
might get it wrong so that's the that's
this paper the tamasic cscw 14 paper I'm
he had a question on your side I was
wondering about you were talking about
with communications of directions when
you have sort of the audit area
information and physical information and
those sort of that the repetition helps
people remove the directions better yeah
so I was wondering like you talked a bit
about if they don't have those sort of
physical directions is that also the
case like um maybe if they're deaf or
something like they have sort of the
physical direction but they don't have
the auditory directions so I so for
deafness it's a little nuance because it
depends on how they interact and how
they communicate so a person who lip
reads and speaks they're going to be
analogous to a hearing person in terms
of the verbal using the verbal channels
of the brain there is some evidence that
sign language does go through both the
spatial and the verbal parts of the
brain so it's a that's a little bit more
of a fuzzy one but I suspect it's still
very heavily in the verbal space the
other thing complicating this is that
sign language does have a spatial
element to it so that one's probably a
little fuzzier
yeah another question okay now you guys
yeah maybe just a little system I'm
thinking about your contribution rates
and it's like ten to fifteen percent
milk yes and you could ask is that good
right when I wonder like maybe his
attendants know what kind of
contribution rates would you need if you
wanted to have like pretty good coverage
for exam okay right so this is what this
particular paper is an interesting paper
because what we did is again we looked
at 10 months worth of data on under a
traditional notion of coverage you think
of all possible trips and a trip is a
bus route at a particular time so you
know the caltrain that's running up to
San Francisco and stopping at the
station right now that is a trip okay as
opposed to a route so if you look at all
the possible trips and all the possible
stops over an entire transit system
we're talking you know it's a huge
number because they want their the
multiplying against each other on our
coverage rate is horrible right but
because we're crowd based we do better
where people are so therefore the right
thing to look at is when you pull up the
app and you see and you look at like
where and when people want data what is
our coverage rate for that and that
number is much better and that's the way
that we think about it from the
perspective of performance and value to
the end users as opposed to the total
coverage question which is actually
really relevant to a transit agency but
to actual riders it's it's less rally
book because you don't particularly care
about the bus that goes out to Half Moon
Bay at 3pm you know yeah um it's always
nice to have more standard computer
science response i always want more data
we we intentionally did not advertise
very much in this particularly because
we're because we're looking at some
other studies with decay and that's our
thing so we probably could Jenner
more than we have we actually did do a
quick little study where we put ads on
buses for the app just to see you know
how much we got back and it does it does
it did in fact you know increase the
quantity of downloading and an uptick in
respective contribution rates but I
think the right answer is is that you
could look at the are you gender are you
providing enough data to your end users
to give them the data that they want and
then if you're not where and how much
where do you advertise and how much do
you advertise to push that number up to
a level that you want there's a big
question about do you reach a critical
mass at a certain point so when you have
a lot of coverage does contribution go
down or doesn't go up and this is a hard
question to answer because we're not
really at the level where we we were at
that point now that Port Authority is
rolling out a VL that kind of gets close
to that and so one of the questions we
have over the next few months and again
we do kind of over long timescales is to
look at whether or not our contribution
rates go down now that a VL is available
and we're still in the we're still kind
of too early to do that study I think
we're to do that analysis because we
don't in my opinion we don't have enough
data yet because I want data in the
scale of tens of months as opposed to
like one month or two months yeah check
the paper is like the contribution was
the fraction of days that they
contribute ok there's not any resent
that right so this in this paper
contribution rate was measured by
sessions so in a session did you record
that because we're assuming you had a
session at a bus stop that you were
waiting to get on a bus did you then
contribute and that one this one was the
ten percent across the population but
that one is different that's the number
of days that you contributed and I
remember now why we use days we use days
because we were using days as a function
because of the decay rate and things
like that yeah in that particular paper
yeah yeah so the thing with sessions is
like you might open the app in the morn
you might not open the app in the
morning when you're going to work
because that bus is almost always on
time
as the time of day that you catch it but
in the evening it's really you know
maybe it's not always on time because
you got to wait for it to work its way
all the way out of the city to pick you
up so so sessions is is relevant for
some kinds of analyses but another case
is like if you're looking at the K over
time then then days makes more sense
yeah all right let's say
you